the new ibm watson query the ga of
netezza performance server as a service
on microsoft azure and an exciting
partnership between ibm cloud satellite
and alibaba cloud all on this episode of
ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
given that it's the holiday season we're
all about giving the gift of making your
lives easier at the end of 2021 so if
you've been seeking to simplify your
data landscape and your life i've got
something for you
we're proud to announce ibm watson query
a universal query engine that will
finally allow you to get all your data
in one view
watson query for ibm cloud pack for data
as a service executes distributed and
virtualized queries across databases
data warehouses and data lakes without
additional manual changes data movement
or replication
among the many features to make your
life easier watson query recommends when
caching would be most useful and
automatically generates the sql to do so
it also allows you to query data
directly in the data lake without
duplication or movement
the new service is a key piece in
accessing your data fabric allowing you
to connect govern data quickly to your
end applications for faster quality
results
ibm watson query is available to try
free for your first 30 days so click the
link in the description of this video to
get started
next up i'm excited to announce the
immediate general availability of ibm
netezza performance server as a fully
managed service on microsoft azure
the netezza cloud data warehouse service
is ibm's modern enterprise data
warehouse for actionable insights
customer hardened and proven neteza
gives you more time to innovate with
zero management
it offers the most performant scalable
and sophisticated modern cloud warehouse
with as a service capabilities some of
these include
ultimate control with granular elastic
scaling no awkward pauses predictable
price and performance simplicity and
sophistication
to unwrap neteza and give it a test
drive click the link below for more info
to close out our final episode of 2021
let's take a look at an exciting
partnership between ibm cloud satellite
and alibaba cloud
ibm cloud satellite is ibm's hybrid
cloud solution allowing clients the
flexibility to run workloads anywhere
they need them in an exciting step to
address data residency needs of clients
in asia pacific and around the globe ibm
cloud satellite is now supported on
alibaba cloud
this will unlock use cases in the region
such as the ability to modernize
applications consistently across a
hybrid multi-cloud environment
you'll also be able to get faster
insights by co-locating data and
artificial intelligence services
we're thrilled to be able to use ibm
cloud satellite to meet clients where
they are on alibaba cloud and other
infrastructures of their choice to learn
more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now i'm
excited to be back in 2022 with some big
changes and updates to the series if
you're interested in learning more about
the topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you